انطلقت اليوم هنا في العاصمه الاوغنديه
كمبالا القمه 19 لدول عدم الانحياز هذه
القمه التي شارك فيها عدد كبير من رؤساء
الدول والحكومات سيطرت عليها الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه هذه الحرب التي ما
زالت مستمره وجدت انتقادات وكبيره من قبل
رؤساء دول وحكومات وايضا ممثلين منهم رئيس
جنوب افريقيا الذي تحدث في فاتحه اعمال
هذه القمه قال بان جنوب افريقيا تدعو الى
وقف شامل وفوري هذه الحرب وكذلك طالب
بضروره تقديم المساعدات او ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه للفلسطينيين في غزه
كذلك رئيس جنوب افريقيا قال بان جنوب
افريقيا طلبت من محكمه العدل الدوليه
العمل على وضع اجراءات تمنع اسرائيل من
الارتكاب المزيد من الجرائم في فلسطين وفي
غزه ايضا هذه القمه تحدث فيها موسى فكير
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي الذي طالب
دول عدم الانحياز بدعم الشعب الفلسطيني
الذي قال بانه يقاتل من اجل الحريه
والكرامه وايضا طالب دول عدم الانحياز
بدعم مساعي الاتحاد الافريقي في الحصول
على مقعد دائم في مجلس الامن الدولي من
اجل المساهمه في السلم والامن الدوليين
حتى تتمكن القاره من المساهمه في ايجاد حل
حله مشاكل القاره الافريقيه العديد ايضا
من رؤساء الدول والممثلين تحدثوا في هذه
القمه و معظمهم اجمعوا على ضروره وقف
الحرب الاسرائيليه في غزه